y revisando los libros que ahí se
mostraban que eran los más vendidos me
di cuenta que había un tema en común un
tema constante que compartían esos
libros que era el tema del éxito el tema
de cómo alcanzar tus metas
cómo conseguir tus logros y cómo era
posible que fuera un tema que tanta
gente quisiera escribir y tanta gente
quisiera leer y pensando sobre esto me
pareció bastante lógico porque creo que
el tema del éxito de alguna forma
interpela una cosa con una todos
ahorita comentaban en el fondo todas las
personas queremos ser exitosas si
hiciera cuesta me queda claro que nadie
quisiera que su vida fuera un acaso
y si a todos nosotros nos dijeran te voy
a dar un manual de cómo ser exitoso
seguramente que todos lo compraríamos
por eso es lógico que sean los libros
más vendidos pero con esto quisiera
hacer la primera pregunta del día de hoy
que es preguntarnos qué es el éxito para
ti y para ti y qué es el éxito porque
realmente creo que de la respuesta a
esta pregunta qué es el éxito depende
mucho porque lo normal es que de eso que
queremos que ese éxito es donde en donde
vamos todas nuestras fuerzas todas
nuestras ganas ahí ponemos pues todo lo
que tenemos en esa idea que tenemos
éxito por eso es tan importante poder
responderlas
y pensando en esto quisiera que hacer un
ejercicio y que todos podamos llevar
nuestra imaginación hacia lo vaya a
hacer nuestro funeral la típica imagen
de un funeral y pensar que nos gustaría
que la gente que esté en nuestro funeral
en tu funeral en mi funeral esté
platicando quizá no nos gustaría que
estuvieran platicando
pues esta persona tuvo mucho dinero o
poco dinero o viajo mucho viajo poco
pero si kiss gustaría que estuvieran
hablando de que significamos nosotros
para ellos del impacto de nuestra vida
sus vidas
y al pensar en este ejemplo me acordaba
de un funeral al que fue una gran
oportunidad de asistir que fue
concretamente el funeral de mi abuela
1998 yo tenía 10 años y recuerdo
perfectamente al llegar al funeral a ver
el lugar repetto de personas repleto de
personas y mientras íbamos en el cortejo
fúnebre hacia el panteón yo iba en la
caja de un pick up junto con algunos
primos y al voltear hacia atrás y ver
las calles repletas de personas aquello
estaba lleno de personas que querían
seguir y acompañar a esa persona en su
último día
y mientras me detenía a escuchar lo que
esas personas practicaban me daba cuenta
que platicaban anécdotas de aquella
persona a la que acompañaban
y como había sembrado en cada uno de
ellos algo
y concretamente mientras la vela van
unos minutos antes recuerdo una tía
platicando una cosa que le sucedió
una ocasión tras ella la chica estaban
en su casa y ella era conocida una
persona muy necesitada habitualmente
pasaba a pedir de diferentes tipos casi
siempre comida o dinero o alguna otra
cosa y aquella vez que tocó a la puerta
que habitualmente además iba siempre
vestida de la misma manera y mi abuela
no solamente costura va a darle comida u
otra ayuda sino acostumbra va a
detenerse aunque estuviera muy ocupada
porque además tuvo ocho hijos aunque
tuviera muy ocupada siempre se quedaba
con ella platicando por aquí hay unos
primos que podrán aparecer se quedaba
con ella platicando y en esa ocasión
volteo con la que contaba la anécdota
que era una niña y le dice por favor
trae del closet esta ropa que acabo de
comprar en la niña un poquito
sorprendida porque le quisiera dar una
ropa nueva le dijo oye y por qué le
quiere esa ropa nueva
si tienes mucha ropa usada que le podría
dar ella le responde no
tú y yo tenemos muchas veces
oportunidades de estas cosas pero ella
no y yo el día de hoy quiero darle
unidad de que estrené algo
y al escuchar esta negó que no me
pareció lógico me pareció razonable que
aquel lugar estuviera repleto que
hubiera gente en ríos de acompañándolo
porque cada uno de ellos tenía una
historia que contar de aquella persona
y creo que al final de la vida de una
persona dices pues creo que esa es una
vida exitosa
esa es una vida que se la pasó sembrando
los demás dejando huella en los demás
con esto me acordaba de una palabra que
me gusta mucho que es una virtud y que
es la virtud de la magnanimidad que está
puesto de dos palabras que una es magno
que significa grande y la otra es anima
y que es como la característica de las
almas grandes y que no se refiere a la
grande con cartera grande con carro
grande sino con alma grande y quizá por
eso mismo muchas veces es como escribir
porque solamente lo entiendes cuando
convives con ellas a la hora de platicar
con ellas de trabajar codo con codo en
el escritorio de jugar de convivir alma
grande y si pudiéramos como resumir lo
que son las personas más y más
yo quisiera resumirlo diciendo son las
personas que se acostumbran a dar lo
mejor de sí en todo lo que hacen
y por eso pues efectivamente dejan
huella en los demás porque se
acostumbran a dar lo mejor de sí en todo
lo que hacen habitualmente están pues
entregándose por completo en aquello que
están haciendo personas magnánimas
recordaba
también con esto quisiera hacer la
segunda pregunta de hoy que es si en
alguna ocasión alguno de ustedes ha
estado en la cárcel
no tienen por qué responder la pregunta
yo estuve en la cárcel
estando en la universidad
mientras nos presentaban algunas
opciones de servicios sociales estamos
ahí en el salón y había un servicio
social que por cierto nadie había
escogido que era el del tutelar el de la
cárcel para menores y yo con este gusto
un poco al reto que tengo voltea a ver a
fernando un gran amigo mío que estaba
ahí al lado de él pregunté fer como veis
y nos metemos a la cárcel y él un poco
dudoso no muy convencido de aquella idea
dijo pues es que no sé después de un
forcejeo amistoso lo logramos convencer
y después a dos amigos más a checo y a
gómez y habíamos los cuatro a la cárcel
y llegamos el primer día la cárcel con
la profesora encargada de los servicios
sociales
y nosotros iremos vestidos de pants de
tenis y de playera deportiva y la
profesora nos recibe diciendo los
muchachos ustedes les va a tocar dar
clases de alfabetización a niños de
entre 13 y 18 años
fuerte preguntaba si alguien hubiera
estado en la cárcel
respira un ambiente muy tenso
clases de alfabetización a niños de
entre 13 y 18 años 15 y les pido un
primo
que no se vengan vestidos así que salen
en vestidos de zapatos pantalón y camisa
porque estos muchachos tienen muchos
problemas y uno de ellos es que tiene
una gran crisis de autoridad y yo
necesito que ustedes nos vean como unos
amiguitos sino que los respeten que
generen distancia con ellos para la real
prenda
el día llegando
a la clase la maestra nos había dado
unas cartulinas y unos pulmones entonces
pues fernando y yo estudiamos ingeniería
en ninguna experiencia pedagogos de
maestros normalistas ni de profesores
entonces después de rebotar 23 ideas
pedagógicas inventadas pues se nos
ocurrió empezar a escribir el abecedario
abs de fg
y empezamos dice
y me resigno
esta primera letra se pronuncia
esto para nosotros quizá es una tontería
pero para un niño que un signo no le
significa nada no le dicen nada no sabe
cómo se pronuncia es mucho me sorprendía
ver a un muchacho de 18 años de 17 años
con una cara de sorpresa escuchando como
cosas nuevas y cuando las juntas con la
r se pronuncia ar y ellos
sorprendidísimos
habitualmente después de la clase les
dejamos las típicas planas hay que
escribir cinco veces las 50 veces la vez
50 veces la cee entonces en una de esas
clases terminando pues muchos ya es hora
nos tenemos que ir y uno de estos
muchachos no profesor todavía no termino
dije bueno de todos modos ya nos tenemos
que ir
y mi hijo no profesor es que yo quiero
aprender a leer y escribir
y yo aprovecho la oportunidad para
preguntarle por qué quisieras aprender a
leer y es que él me dice profesor es que
yo quiero ser doctor
pues a mí esas palabras esa frase me
dejó absolutamente sin palabras
encontrar ese deseo tan noble tan limpio
tan alto de superar así de salir
adelante en las peores circunstancias en
las que pueda estar una persona me dejó
absolutamente sin palabras
lamentablemente me encontré con los
casos contrarios son muchacho de mes no
profesor a mí no me interesa aprender a
leer y escribir porque yo conozco
personas que tienen dinero que tienen
lujos y que no son grandes estudiantes
lamentablemente estos muchachos pues
muchas veces tenían ejemplos que no les
ayudaban
y efectivamente pues al entrar semana en
esta temporada a la cárcel pues entraba
con un poco de miedo con un poco de
reserva con un poco suspect por estos
muchachos
y la verdad es que me llevé una gran
lección porque esto es mucho principio
se les saca de la sociedad porque en
principio le hacen daño a la sociedad y
se les intenta reconstruir de lo que me
di cuenta es que más que ellos le
hicieran daño a la sociedad eran
personas a las que la sociedad les había
hecho mucho daño
y que eran personas como mientras como
deseosas de que hubiera otros que
dejaran de destruir en ellos y empiezan
a construir personas tremendamente
nobles tremendamente buenas con ganas de
superarse y salir adelante en
circunstancias mucho peores que la de
muchos de nosotros
entonces con esto pues yo sí me había
convencido de que muchas veces nosotros
somos en buena parte el resumen el
resultado de la huella que otras
personas han dejado en nosotros
todos nosotros nuestros profesores
nuestros compañeros en mi caso mis
compañeros de esta maestría que un gran
ejemplo de que las cosas se pueden hacer
bien y grandes cuando se trabaja y
cuando se quiere
como pues haciéndose con estos muchachos
encontré muchachos con grandes huellas
que muchas veces con grandes cicatrices
y a veces con grandes heridas
hace unos días tuve la oportunidad de
estar en guadalajara que es mi tierra
natal y tenía mis brazos a una niña
hermosa que es maria sophia que es mi
sobrina y que está cumpliendo 10 meses
de nacida pues al tenerla ahí yo no
podía dejar de pensar pues como mucho de
lo que en ella se construya y mucho de
lo que hay en ella en lo que yo vaya a
dejarle y lo que los demás que
convivimos con ella vayamos a dejarle
es una fotografía unos días que tuve
oportunidad de estar con mi padre
guillermo pérez y con esto quisiera
hacer la tercer y última pregunta de
este día que es pensar quiénes son esas
personas que han dejado huella en tu
vida y en la mía esas personas que
gracias a ellos somos lo que somos y
somos quien somos efectivamente sí creo
que muchas veces nuestras decisiones nos
hacen pero también en gran medida la
huella que dejan los demás hacen que
seamos lo que somos
y creo que a veces cortando la imagen
del funeral cuando se puede catalogar
que la vida de una persona fue exitosa
esas personas magnánimas esas personas
que se acostumbran a habitualmente lo
mejor de sí en todo lo que hacen por ser
así por comportarse así van dejando
huella en los compañeros los amigos en
la gente con la que conviven
personas magnánimas que dejan huella en
los demás por eso no sirve pensar que no
siempre es el éxito esa magnanimidad es
con cosas tremendamente extraordinarias
porque las personas que más voy han
dejado a nosotros quizá no han hecho
cosas espectaculares
pero si han hecho muchas cosas pequeñas
de forma espectacular y eso es lo que
nos deja marcados esa es la huella de
muchas vidas exitosas que a final de
cuentas son esas vidas magnánimas pues
que van sembrando constantemente en los
demás muchas gracias
[Aplausos]